Pick somebody in your life and you send
them a message asking them how their day
is going on a scale of one to 10 and
it's very important that you ask them on
a scale of one to 10 for a couple of
reasons,
you'll actually get more interesting
answer because usually,
you know if somebody says a three or an
eight,
they'll explain it a little bit and
suddenly you're getting a little more in
depth information than you would
normally get if you had just asked them
how,
how are you doing?
Oh,
I'm fine,
or I'm tired or I'm hungry.
And then when you do get a reply,
what you do is you immediately texts
back or write back and say,
is there anything I can do to make that
number plus one?
Anything I could do to move you from a
three to a four or from an eight to a
nine.
And that shows that you are really
willing to take some time and effort to
do,
you know,
little favorites.
It's a little boost for your friend.
We know in looking at video games,
so this is one of the reasons why video
games are such effective relationship
management tools,
specifically social games like Farmville
or candy crush saga.
Lots of research has shown that when you
play these games regularly with people,
you become more likely to talk to them
about non game topics.
You do that more frequently and you're
also more likely to ask them for help
with a real life problem or more willing
to offer them help and the reason why is
the design of the Games supports more
frequent interactions which are really
important for building up that kind of
relationship and also to show
reciprocity where you are asking someone
for help or you are offering help and
you think about a game like farmville
where you can go water some of these
crops or feed their chickens for them.
Or Candy Crush Saga where I'm constantly
asking my inlaws to send me extra lives
and I'm sending them little power booths
in the game.
That little act of reciprocity,
I'm willing to help you.
You're willing to help me and doing it
regularly.
You know,
everyday or a couple times a week that
firmly cements in somebody's mind the
idea of you as an ally and you might
have people that you want to have
thinking of you that way,
that aren't playing any of these video
games.
So the plus one technique is a way to
make sure that you're talking regularly
about these everyday topics,
but also that you have a chance to give
a little bit of support or help just,
you know,
what,
how can I move you just plus one on this
scale,
something small that I can do today and
it's something that I do quite often
that not only does it help,
you know,
make someone else's Day,
but I kind of enjoyed it when I get the
chance to hear how people are doing and
just do that one little thing to make
their day better.
Parents love it.
Parents will love it.
When you do that,
that's like,
that's like the most prime audience for
this.
They will write you back a paragraph on
why it's an eight day and then,
and then you offered you plus one and
their dislike.
It's already plentiful on because you
wrote.